exhausting always rooting for the
anti-hero Taylor Swift dropped her 10th
studio album midnights at well midnight
featuring yeah you guessed it 13 tracks
and surprise seven bonus songs each
telling a story of sleepless nights
throughout the course of the Grammy
Winner's life the concept of the album
midnights is the extreme emotions you
might be feeling in the middle of the
night what keeps you up at night so that
covers everything from grief to sadness
to fear to anger to flirtation or
daydreaming about someone or falling in
love or feeling overconfident you know
now we're breaking down some of the
juiciest lyrics and Easter eggs awesome
starting with lavender Haze inspired by
a phrase Taylor says she learned while
watching Mad Men look at you
you're in the lavender Haze it's a
common phrase used in the 50s where they
would just describe being in love like
if you were in the lavender Haze then
that meant that you were in that
all-encompassing love glow the track was
co-written by Swifty's friend Zoe
Kravitz and is about the singer's
six-year romance with Joe Alwyn
[Music]
[Music]
we've had to dodge weird rumors tabloid
stuff and we just ignore it um and so
this song is sort of about the act of
ignoring that stuff to predict to
protect the real stuff and Joe he
collaborated on the 12th track on the
album Sweet Nothing credited under his
now famous pseudonym will Bowery
you're in the kitchen
nothing and in true Taylor fashion the
album features songs seemingly inspired
by her past loves too the ways in which
I like to surprise people are with my
creative choices maroon looks back at a
former relationship that was lost
[Music]
and that lyric has fans thinking it
could be about her ex Tom Hiddleston
whom she famously danced with at the
2016 Met Gala in yes New York
and Taylor's fans think midnight rain is
about the demise of her brief but very
public relationship with Tom
[Music]
[Music]
then there's T Swift's bonus track would
have could have shut up which references
a relationship she had at 19 which has
fans convinced it's about her romance
with John Mayer Who was 32 when they
dated
if I wasn't painted it's louder
on a promising grown man and if I was a
child it didn't matter
if you got to wash your hands she later
sings quote give me back my girl hood it
was mine first they say that when we're
breaking up and they're like you better
not write a song about this and I'm like
oh I won't and then I do but the album
isn't all love and love lost I would
always like to keep people on their toes
in that regard I think that's the best
way to be exciting vigilante appears to
reference her longtime Feud with Kanye
West no Taylor
I'm really happy for you I'm let you
finish but Beyonce had one of the best
videos of all time I was standing on
stage and I was really excited because I
had just won the award and then I was
really excited because Kanye West was on
the stage then I wasn't so excited
anymore after that you did some bad
things but I'm the worst of them
[Music]
sometimes I wonder which one will be
your last lie another possible reference
to the rapper lyrics set seemingly point
to his 2021 split from Kim Kardashian
[Music]
kids gets the pride
pictures thieves with your ex wife
meanwhile fans theorize that karma is
aimed at Scooter Brawn and big machine
records Scott borschetta over the drama
played out amid the battle for her
Masters
Spider Boy
[Music]
foreign